you
let's try this is a start
I usually don't start like this C for D
for e for let's go with this I'll try to
steer it into maybe some type of an
English or not we're gonna have a Dutch
huh okay
let's go with this first and as soon as
black is threatening to play e5
successfully I'll do this okay maybe
maybe I could do without this advance
what should I do
hmm you know maybe there was a reason to
not play my knight here just yet I
wonder if this could be a bit annoying
notice how if I didn't have my knight
develop right away and I went with just
g3 Bishop g2 this would definitely be no
worry to me it would be staring at of
something that's not so great
and the house I guess if I was one move
quicker with going with the fianchetto
maybe black couldn't oppose me on the
Queen side so there we go at the bishop
you know I don't know if I'm so happy
about black doubling my pawns so let's
attack the bishop and be prepared to
recapture it to my queen so I have
picked up the dark square bishop and is
there better diagonal for him to be on
then the main diagonal mm-hmm okay
my hesitation right there was should I
go b3 or b4 I wondered I wondered if I
could get a little bit more out of this
pond and I was saying that I wanted to
stop this advance who you know what this
is a weak point and this bishops are
protected these two aren't protected so
I'm looking for ways to exploit that
moving my knight Bishop takes its on my
rook I probably just have to recapture
if my work were moved I think I could do
this move and take here as an in-between
shop so I wonder in hindsight if moving
my rook was better than b3
is moving my night still a good idea I
don't know let's do this
let's do this
all right maybe I move the rook and then
threaten a knight move I'm not sure
where you should even go uh you know I'm
still gonna go here we're gonna have the
bishops let me let me think for a second
I'm not gonna pre move that 307 about a
minute disadvantage I'm pretty sure I
just have to recapture this Queen here
it's not it's not quite working out so
my knight also has this potentially good
square and this seems very awkward Queen
here but maybe there's something to it
because if pawn push I could take here
ooh night here attacks my queen and my
knight I'd have to play here and
counter-attack the knight and defend my
knight I think I should be okay with
that I'm gonna try it certainly a very
awkward placement for my queen but how
to defend this pawn Knight here might be
needed then I could do this and then
they could do that this is getting to be
a very critical line right now I don't
know how how good this move is to put
pressure on the e6
there's also Knight here I take on e5
let's check if I take here Knight here
how do I kick that night out of there
yeah yeah there he goes there you go is
that tricky night man he's still around
let's get him out of there oh okay look
at this guy what a bugger huh he's a
bugger is that what you were thinking
okay I feel like I'm close to being in
big trouble
my queen isn't gonna get hit with the
fork is she Queen here would be
threatening made on
- don't fall for made on age - whatever
you do the night sit the Queen could
play here but I have a dump not a double
attack what did I mean to say I'd have a
counter-attacking mouth so I'm not
afraid of that I'm not afraid of your
queen night here night here
'if I've are all possibilities and also
that one Wow
I'm gonna be losing upon I think wow
those nights are way too crazy hmm
I gotta go here there's a very good move
here and that's it I'm losing my bishop
and then my pond but maybe I could get
counterplay against the sea pond this of
course was all calculated on my part all
of it I'm getting him back I'm gonna rip
the heart out of the queenside story no
he's not the heart he's the heart I'm
Gemma sturgeon struggling to get my pond
back my king is exposed on this diagonal
I don't like that not at all so the
knight could be supported but I could
still kick him around my queen be
getting trapped now after she takes here
she's threatening to grab another pond
this Knight needs to go get out of my
house my house there are these four
ranks if you did not know
hmm upon here to take now I mean I'm
getting the pond back I believe I do
have some concern about my king position
no not anymore not not anymore since d5
is here enough to worry as much I'm not
getting trapped I'm on the night
yeah okay I think I have to take and let
me just centralize my queen that seems
like a good idea doesn't it put pressure
on this pawn as the position simplifies
more let's let's just guard him I like
him enough to guard him I don't think
he's expendable maybe that was a better
way to say it so as the position
simplifies a bit more I've noticed the
Queen and one of these four center
squares tends to be a very very good
piece now I think oh I'm not afraid of
that discovered check I'll just drop
back or maybe consider this yeah I'll
just drop back I don't know I'm not sure
to be announced done that one to be
announced I'm still not afraid should I
be my Queens not getting trapped pawn
push I could block now but I'm I'm not
going to do that I think I'm fine where
I'm at and let's take like this and
hopefully there's not gonna be a maid on
each one I should be much faster rook
here okay let me let me take this pawn
and defend f2 okay f2 I need to babysit
and my queen is the babysitter not the
best babysitter around
I just want trade Queens rook here I
also want to throw a pig on that seventh
rank okay I'm okay with this cuz not
relieve some pressure relieve some
pressure on f2 and I want to pinpoint
this this pawn isn't a pin I'm up upon
and I
just want to grab this guy rookie 4 and
d4 to pile up if if we're gonna have
something like this black is putting
themselves in a pin so rook here well
still even with rook here even with rook
here I had this d4 move so this is an
instance of attacking a pinned piece or
pawn exploiting the pin I have all my
bases covered
a3 f2 and my last decision will be to
take with the rook or the pond and I
believe I'll just take with the rook
welcoming more exchanges instead of
trying to get a this guy rolling I want
to have activity with pieces along the
e-file and I am perfectly okay with the
Queen trade this is a one King and pawn
endgame should that have happened let's
take the pawns over here and I like well
I'm just gonna grab him no I'm just
gonna go after this pawn proponents it's
starting to fly let's get back over here
sneak my king up maybe throw that check
in no they're gonna do that first drive
that King back get my pawns up get these
guys rolling keep going
and then look for a check here they were
being sneaky let me be sneaky back out
hang on hahaha what have been stealing
me do you imagine the scream imagine it
imagine that scream well good I had I
had I was hovering over it rook takes
pawn steal me ah good game alright let's
go back and quickly see where either one
of us could have improved okay
tough game Wow interesting middle game
sequence it got very critical I wonder I
wonder about if you are going to part
with the bishop I wonder one thing that
comes to mind for me is is there a way
to do it under more favorable
circumstances like like is it is it
worthwhile to insert first a five this
might be a subtle but important point if
you play a five and I insist I want to
like throw a question the bishop then
then if you take and I recapture I think
a four could turn out to be a nice lock
down on the b3 square and then there
might be new possibilities for Knight a
six to c5 to beat free it's just
something to look into with regard to
the pawn structure and exploiting
potential holes in the white position a5
and make me weak in my B 3 square if I'm
going to kick the bishop away it's a
time waster so that's that's the thing
you'd have to weigh is it worth the time
to grant yourself maybe the b3 square
but you just capture right away and I
have the bishop pair and again I think
at this point I was saying
maybe I should move my rook so that this
move would fail I'm pretty sure to a
knight move exploiting the bishop on
bee7bea and I'm protected as well as the
pawn on e6 but we didn't go in that
direction didn't quite have that I'm
needing to recapture on g2 and I guess I
don't know only the computer is gonna be
able to sort this one out for sure it's
got really crazy
I got ambitious going after the weak
point you can't move after Queen e3
because again f5 Knight g4 Queen here I
always have a check and maybe I got a
knight retreat I think it should be okay
or no I don't know yeah nice and between
moves nice and between moves not
reacting to the threat right away if you
did play Knight 1/4 I was going to play
Bishop seats free but here winds upon
temporarily maybe there was something
better
it's easy to miss the different Knight
moves and this advanced I'm still going
here so I believe I do get that pond
back I'm not sure what else to really
recommend I don't know if I've even
recommended anything I just pointed out
possibilities for a 5 and a 4 earlier
but it was a tough game as is usually
the case with Benko G yeah these I think
well it's already but my queen is in a
good spot and it's tough you can't
contest the C file so easily because you
tethered to this pawns defense
I wonder if king f7 in this in this
endgame where I think it's a lot clearer
that I'm just better in this endgame
because of my Queens strong position I
wonder if you can do something like King
here have your King be the one who's
responsible for watching
and then you have to try and get control
over the C file or not get control but
at least negate the influence I have
over over the C file if you could
envision the position with the King on
f7 in both sets of rooks exchange off
the board which is likely since there's
only one open file I don't know if it
would be enough for like my I don't know
if my queens position would be good
enough
your Queen could always play to d7 and
your guarding your base points be a much
more difficult struggle maybe maybe this
is something oh no you can't do it right
away you can't do it right away because
of rook c7 so there goes that idea maybe
no you can't even do it now maybe right
now instead of Queen b7 rook c8 at this
moment can test it right now and then
think about rook here or yeah rook here
King here in that bad idea yeah doing it
out doing it one move later it's it's
not quite working in fact why didn't I
play here I know oh man look at the
things I missing book seats ooh how
stupid how stupid I played here for a
reason not to just stare along this file
but to go to squares in your territory
rook c7 man okay
another reason why I'm queen here was
not good but I did not take advantage
that did it did I did it or did I I'm
tongue tied all of a sudden as well
maybe not all of a sudden you know just
been off all along I'm just turning my
head to the right looking at the twitch
chat and it's going bonkers saying
finally finally he sees it he's been
babbling for hours okay
missed opportunity I don't think I gave
it away but there was certainly a much
cleaner approach the rock endgame is
winning when you winning and I'm glad to
have not grabbed that pond I'm pretty
sure I was hovering over it just ready
to unclick followed by a scream I
avoided that okay
good game Benko gene
you